this video is sponsored by war thunder a
realistic free to play military vehicle
combat game it's available on pc ps5 xbox
series x and previous generations of consoles
as well no need to purchase anything just download
and play in this game there are more than 2 000
historically accurate tanks helicopters ships
and other vehicles spanning the entire 20th
century they're all carefully built and incredibly
detailed operating in a realistic physics engine
it's an immersive gaming experience with real
historical campaigns even the sound is incredible
and you can just jump in for a quick arcade
game which is great if you're pressed for time
or you're just looking for something casual
i personally prefer just to jump in and give
something a play i'm pretty busy dude don't have
time to dedicate to learning all the complexities
i just want a bit of fun but if you're a bit more
hardcore you could play realistic go for some
challenging tactical stuff right now you can join
war thunder and its 50 million worldwide players
on the battlefield for free using the link below
and for those of you that do jump into the game
using my link war thunder is giving you a free
premium tank aircraft or ship plus three days of
premium play for free it's a great deal and thanks
to war thunder of sponsoring and now today's video
new crime reporter leo catcher said that arnold
rothstein transformed organized crime from
a thuggish activity practiced by hoodlums
into a big business run like a corporation
with himself at the top he gathered the loose
single strands of crime and wove them into a
tapestry he took the various elements
that were needed to change crime from
petty larceny into big business and fused them the
end result was a machine that runs smoothly today
a bit overdramatic perhaps but it does well
to illustrate the impact that arnold rothstein
had on crime in america all of the notorious
mobsters that you've heard of who have already
been featured here on biographics lucky luciano
melansky frank costello they all learned their
business from the man known as the brain mr
big and the big bankroll arnold rothstein
arnold rothstein was born on january the 17th 1882
in new york city he was the second son of abraham
and esther rothstein he was part of a wealthy and
influential ashkenazi jewish family and he grew
up in luxury in a swanky home in manhattan abraham
rothstein also known as abe the just in his local
community was a man who cherished philanthropy
piety and honesty and also served as chairman on
the board of the best israel hospital his oldest
son harry studied to become a rabbi arnold on the
other hand didn't really follow in their footsteps
in fact the only thing he seemed to inherit from
his father was his business acumen from a young
age arnold resented his older brother harry since
he felt that he received most of the care and
attention from their parents according to an
interview with a psychologist the most emotional
moment in rostein's childhood occurred when he was
six years old and his father found him hiding and
sobbing uncontrollably in a closet screaming that
everybody hated him and loved harry his jealousy
only grew as the years passed especially when
harry announced that he wanted to enter rabbinical
school to the great delight of his father gambling
was another driving wedge between young arnold
and his father as you might imagine abe rothstein
disapproved of gambling whereas arnold never found
a pair of dice that he didn't like as soon as he
won his first part arnold knew that it didn't
get any better than that nothing and nobody could
persuade him to stop school didn't mean much for
arnold either the only subject where he showed any
interest was arithmetic he was great with numbers
but that only was because he saw that they could
be used to make him become a better gambler he got
held back a few times and by the time he turned 16
he dropped out of school completely rothstein then
took a few jobs as a traveling salesman he was
good at it and enjoyed the work but it simply
didn't make enough cash to keep his interest
no if rothstein was going to maintain the
comfortable lifestyle that he grew accustomed to
he would need to find more lucrative business
opportunities a strange moment in his life
occurred when rothstein was around 18 years old
still a traveling salesman at that point he was in
eerie pennsylvania when he received a message from
home his older brother harry the sibling that he
had resented his whole life had died of pneumonia
this was a turning point in rothstein's life
for a while harry's death persuaded him to try
one last time to mend the relationship that he
had with his father he moved back home stayed away
from his usual gambling haunts and even went to
synagogue with abe it was a nice gesture but it
didn't last long eventually he had another row
with his father and he left the family home again
this time determined to strike out on his own from
that moment on arnold rothstein fully embarked
on his life of crime and he never looked back
for the next few years of rothstein's life
the pool halls bookies and gambling denzel
new york became his new home away from home uh
hammerstein's victoria theater and the broadway
central hotel were favorite hangouts of his and
rothstein already started to acquaint himself with
some of the locals of dubious reputation who
frequented such dens of iniquity soon enough
he had saved up enough money to become a loan
shark nothing major just fifty dollars here and
a hundred dollars there but rostein was good at
making himself appear like a bigger deal than
he actually was he developed a habit of always
carrying around a lot of dollar bills thick enough
to choke a pelican he would flash it every time he
got the opportunity to make it seem like that was
just some walking around money to him when in fact
it was most of the cash that he had in the world
rostein also showed himself eager to spend it more
than happy to fund other people's gambling habits
as long as they paid it back with 25 interest
and those who refused to pay well let's just say
that they would receive a nasty visit from some of
arnold's pals rothstein himself didn't like to get
his hands dirty but he had associates who had no
such qualms sooner or later everybody paid up it
was around this time that rothstein's profile grew
large enough that he started hanging out with a
better class of criminals the crooked politicians
specifically timothy big tim sullivan one of the
tammany hall bigwigs who controlled the democratic
vote in several areas of manhattan 20 years older
than rothstein sullivan was already a force to
be reckoned with by the time the young gambler
started breaking into the new york underworld a
mentorship relationship began evolving between the
two just like the one that rothstein would later
develop with future mobsters such as lucky luciano
and frank costello sullivan taught rothstein the
importance of building a network of relations
everyone from janitors to judges had
some kind of value if you used them right
people soon learned that if they had a tip
for any kind of money-making opportunity be it
legal or illegal arnold rothstein was the one
willing to pay top dollar for it with such insider
information he moved up from small-time pool
hall games to big poker tournaments horse races
prize fights any crooked game in new york you
could bet on arnold rothstein would be there
he once quipped that he would bet on anything
except the weather since it was the only thing
he couldn't control in 1907 rothstein met and fell
in love with a 19 year old showgirl named carolyn
greene he intended to marry her and even brought
her to meet his parents although this had the
predictable outcome of an argument between father
and son the devout abraham blew a fuse when he
found out that his son's half-jewish bride-to-be
had been raised catholic and had no intention
of converting of course his father's approval was
not high on arnold rothstein's list of priorities
especially since he wasn't exactly genesis prize
material either the couple stayed together despite
a rothsted's protestations and two years later
they got married in saratoga springs as rostein's
fortune grow it made sense for him to open his
own gambling house which he did with the help
from sullivan who offered him protection on his
new joint sullivan's assistance did come with a
bothersome catch though as rothstein had to take
on a former building inspector named william cher
as a partner cher was an anti-semite who
distrusted rothstein so unsurprisingly the
two butted heads quite often until one night when
rothstein took the drunken share into signing away
his side of the partnership for forty thousand
dollars once that little annoyance was dealt with
rostein got back to what mattered most to him
making money his casino was located inside two
brownstones on west 46th street near the theater
district and as you entered it became evident that
it wasn't the kind of joint where you would drop
a few nickels and dimes no rothstein's gambling
house was the type of place where the showgirls
were friendly and the liquor was plentiful
and it was obviously intended to attract big
time spenders with deep pockets and poor judgment
by the time he turned 30 in 1912 arnold rothstein
had become a millionaire he never stopped gambling
of course but he also expanded his portfolio by
dipping his fingers in a lot of profitable pies
loan sharking smuggling bail bonding anything
that would make money rothstein didn't have
a crew his speciality was putting the right
people in contact with each other or working
on the business end of a racket his role was
that of a fixer or a go-between but of course
he always collected his cut it was also around
this time that he began acting as a mentor to
some of the up-and-coming mobsters who worked for
him guys like mayor lansky jack leggs diamond and
lucky luciano all studied under the tree of
rothstein and later expressed their admiration
for his talents lansky said that rothstein had the
most remarkable brain when it came to business and
that he would have become rich and successful even
if it stayed legitimate meanwhile lucky revealed
that his relationship with ross dean was more
than strictly business luciano said he taught
me how to dress how to use knives and forks
and things like that at the dinner table about
holding a door open for a girl if arnold had
lived a little longer he could have made me pretty
elegant one of the things that made rothstein
so valuable as a partner was his connection
to the new york political machine according
to crime writer leah catcher everyone turned
to arnold lawyers fixers people in trouble
sought him out he was a pipeline to tammany
hall if you wanted a favor from the hall arnold
rothstein could expedite it assure it for you
and so you paid him 1913 was a pivotal
year for rothstein because two of new
york's most influential and most corrupt
political players were taken out of the game
one was his former mentor big tim sullivan or the
king of the bowery as he liked to be called who
died in september 1913 when his body was almost
sliced into by a speeding train the circumstances
under which he ended up on the train tracks
are still up for debate was it murder suicide
or accident the other bigwig who bit the dust was
police captain charles becker who was arrested for
planning and ordering the 1912 murder of bookie
herman rosenthal becker was not only convicted but
also executed for the crime becoming one of the
few crooked cops to face capital punishment this
could have been a big problem for rothstein
as he lost two of his biggest connections
in the same year but fortunately for him the more
things changed the more they stayed the same old
acquaintances were simply replaced by new ones
and his role remained mostly the same if anything
his criminal empire continued to grow as rothstein
opened two new casinos in long island and saratoga
and also started getting involved in the drug
trade his setup in saratoga in particular was
said to be among the swankiest ones in the
country known as the brook it combined a
casino with a restaurant a nightclub and a cabaret
show and it attracted some of the biggest gamblers
in america mobsters like bugsy siegel and mayor
lansky would emulate his pension for luxury with
their own establishments in the future but it was
rothstein who first thought to invest in deluxe
businesses in order to attract a higher class of
clientele one of the few times that rothstein got
into trouble with the law happened in 1919 when
police conducted a raid on a gambling den when
the detectives started pounding the door they
were met with gunshots there were only a few
minor injuries and the entire party was arrested
including rothstein and his bodyguard even though
nodey identified the shooter rothstein was caught
trying to get rid of a revolver so he was the one
indicted on assault charges nothing ever came
of it though a judge dismissed the charges on
the basis of a faulty raid because the officers
didn't identify themselves as police and a faulty
indictment because no evidence was submitted
to directly implicate rothstein as the shooter
whether the ruling was legitimate or rothstein
simply bribed his way out the end result was the
same arnold was a free man and he could get back
to business and his plans grew even more ambitious
with the world of crime being inherently
secretive even to its own members it is
unsurprising that it has given rise to numerous
myths rumors and legends jimmy hoffer being
buried under giant stadium is a popular example
but perhaps none is more pervasive than arnold
rothstein fixing the 1919 baseball world series
just to be clear we're not saying that he did
or did not do it neither side has ever been
proven conclusively we're simply presenting
the story as it has been told for over a hundred
years it was october 1919 and the american league
champion chicago white sox were due to meet the
national league champion cincinnati reds in a best
of nine series to determine the winners of the
world series ultimately the reds t153 but rumors
started flying around that the games had not been
on the up and up was it possible that some of
the chicago players intentionally threw the game
and was it possible that they were paid to do so
by arnold rothstein who made a killing by betting
against the favorites let's examine the story bit
by bit first off why would the chicago players
throw the series well athletes back then had only
a teeny tiny fraction of the wealth and power that
they have today the owner of the chicago white
sox charles kamiski was known as a particularly
parsimonious miser who paid his players peanuts
one of his star athletes schuler's joe jackson
who was still ranked as one of the greatest
hitters in the history of the game only made six
thousand dollars a year which is around 85 000
today meanwhile many other players made just three
thousand dollars which today would be below the
national salary average in other words it was
a far far cry from the multiple hundred million
dollar contracts of today then there was also the
dreaded reserve clause back then there was no free
agency so players couldn't move on to greener
pastures when their contracts expired their team
still retained the rights to them essentially in
perpetuity and they could only move to another
team if they received an unconditional release
from their previous team all of this was done to
explicitly keep the players salaries low since
freedom of movement would have increased demand
and therefore granted players leverage to ask
for higher wages honestly the way things were
it's kind of surprising that more baseball players
didn't just say screw it and throw the game for
one big payday but it did happen on this occasion
eight white sox players were implicated in the
scandal including the aforementioned shoeless
joe jackson they were indicted on conspiracy to
defraud charges and brought before a grand jury
ultimately the black socks as they were dubbed by
the media were all found not guilty but they were
still banned for life from professional baseball
so where does arnold rothstein come in allegedly
he was the shadowy figure behind the scenes who
bankrolled the entire operation two gamblers
came to him with the idea both of them having
connections to the white sox one was joseph sport
sullivan and the other was william sleepy bill
burns rothstein went with sullivan since he had a
better reputation and paid him between 80 000 to
100 000 to arrange the whole thing but as we know
there is no honor among thieves and it was alleged
during the trial that sullivan only turned over
fifteen thousand dollars to the players and kept
the rest somewhere definitely got screwed over in
this deal but it certainly wasn't arnold rothstone
rumors say that he placed several bets on the
cincinnati reds totaling almost 270 thousand
dollars and that he walked away with a princely
sum out of the whole ordeal however he was called
to testify before the grand jury in october 1920
but he couldn't be tied to anything so rothstein
was cleared of any involvement and strangely
enough some historians agree with this assessment
and think that rothstein was truthful when he said
that he had no part in the fix he was certainly
aware of it you couldn't plan a scam this big back
then without word reaching arnold rothstein he
also knew that other people used his name while
organizing the whole thing to make it seem like
a big time deal but he chose to keep his mouth
shut and stay away from the whole matter quietly
making his own bets it was just the way rothstein
liked it all of the wins with none of the risks
the thing is that as notorious as the black
sox betting scandal was it wasn't even close
to rothstein's biggest payday just in 1921 alone
he made two bets that earned him five hundred
thousand dollars in eight hundred and fifty
thousand dollars respectively horse racing was
his sport of choice and he even owned a few horses
including two champion racers named sidereel and
sporting blood who both won him those two huge
bets and the truth is that these kind of massive
gambling wins weren't even rothstein's main
moneymaker anymore because in 1920 something
new came along that turned arnold rothstein
into one of the richest gangsters in the country
prohibition january the 17th 1920 was described
as the greatest day for organized crime in america
because that is when prohibition came into effect
and rothstein was the kind of guy who immediately
spotted the huge profits to be made just waiting
for the right man with the right vision to come
along and he was that man so he started repairing
even before the volstead act as it was also
known came into effect therefore when prohibition
arrived rothstein was ready he had the connections
he had the delivery network and he had that sweet
sweet nectar of the gods to keep america tipsy and
happy because he was one of the first criminals
to get in on the action arnold rothstein became
one of the biggest bootleggers of the early 1920s
as the years passed he got outmatched by guys like
al capone and george remus but by then rothstein
had already reaped his riches not to mention that
he expanded into the heroin and cocaine trade so
he was still doing all right for himself the 1920s
represented the peak of arnold rosstein's power
influence and wealth but they ended with a sudden
and permanent drop if you know what we mean
on november 4th 1928 rothstein was shot while
attending a meeting inside the park central hotel
he was found by the service entrance trying to
hail a cab to go to a doctor he was taken to the
hospital where doctors pulled a 38-caliber bullet
out of rothstein's abdomen which appears to an
artery and caused a lot of bleeding initially it
was thought that he might survive but the kingpin
died of his injuries two days later on november
6th aged 46 during his day in hospital he regained
consciousness but stuck to the precious code of
silence until his last breath refusing to tell
the cops anything other than his age and address
now again we'll dip into the bag of mafia law
for the reason for rothstein's murder since
nobody was ever convicted of the crime the whole
thing supposedly happened over an unpaid gambling
debt weeks earlier rothstein attended a card game
hosted by a guy named george mcmanus this was
where arnold was matched up against two other big
time gamblers called alvin titanic thompson and
nate raymond rothstein was uncharacteristically
unlucky that day and he left the table owing over
three hundred thousand dollars everyone expected
him to make good on the payment but days turned
to weeks and still no word from arnold as it
turned out he became convinced that the game
had been fixed and had no intention of paying this
put mcmanus in a delicate position since he hosted
the game and therefore vouched for everyone at the
table he demanded a private meeting with rostein
at the park central hotel where we presume a lot
of accusations and insults started flying around
and arnold rothstein left the room with a hole
in his gut as we said nobody was convicted so
his murder remains officially unsolved and the
funny thing is that the money would have meant
nothing to rothstein just days after his death bet
of his came up and it would have earned him over
half a million dollars his debt was just a tiny
drop in the bucket to him but it was the idea
that he had been conned that he couldn't stand he
died letting the world know that arnold rothstein
was nobody's sucker so i really hope you enjoyed
today's video if you'd like to check out another
video that we've done about gangsters one
mentioned in today's video please do check
out our bugsy seagull video which i'll link to
on the screen now and thank you for watching
thanks again to war thunder for sponsoring
today's video remember to follow the link
in the description below to start playing
their free vehicle combat game with three
free days of premium play and a premium vehicle
as well go check it out thank you for watching